[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
all right happy monday
in times of unease and confusion it
helps to have a leader come out and do
something bold
to tell us that life is okay and we can
return to normal
it's like what your dad used to do after
exiting the bathroom with a can of lysol
everything was now under control
well the greatest man in the history of
the world is back
no not him him
yes our former 44th president has given
a middle finger to the cdc by inviting
over 500 people
to his 60th birthday party at his 12
million dollar martha
vineyard mansion it's the beach house
bash that shows america
that there's no reason to be worried
about covid or rising sea levels
yep climate change and corona are
officially dead according to this news
although i think my invite got lost in
the mail or mixed up with all those love
letters from megan fox
apparently the guests will be wined and
dined by over 200 staffers
200 boy i bet border patrol in texas is
green with envy yeah i wonder how the
wall of security at this party would
take to a bunch of party-goers just
showing up to manny to be let in
and i wonder if you bring a kid you'll
be letting free just like at our border
now pearl jam was supposed to play at
this uh party but now
they deny it that's probably good
wow they really are a thinking man's
abba
now all guests will have to be tested in
facts and there's going to be a covid
coordinator to make sure people follow
precautions
i guess that's how fauci got his invite
now uh this news comes amid an increase
in the delta
variant in the ensuing media panic a
panic however that doesn't go near obama
for holding a bash during a pandemic
but i salute him and the message he's
sending which is rather than shut down
your lives again it's time to throw
fauchi to the wind
and live your life death comes for all
of us whether it's the miniscule risk
of a vaccinated person gets from covid
or at the giant risk
of getting murdered in portland the real
challenge isn't simply the virus it's
overcoming those who politicize this
in order to divide a country too bad
there isn't a vaccine to protect us from
cnn's misinformation
but based on their ratings it would take
only about 50 doses
i wonder what the angry white male has
to say
[Music]
come on let barack obama have a party
would you i mean what a man decides to
do in the privacy of his own
island mansion is his business of course
i wouldn't go to the party even if i was
invited
not because i'm concerned about covet 19
but
i just prefer more solitary activities
like uh
i don't know riding ski lifts alone in
the summer
[Music]
[Applause]
you know he just dumped a body what
about the angry blackmail
[Music]
oh sometimes when i stick my hands in
the chip bags it's so big the bag rips
open
i'm sure it's a common problem but i'm
sure that's not what you're here for
so what speak your mind
what president barack obama's throwing a
party
great good for him we need more parties
in this country
i don't think it's great that president
trump is throwing rallies which are kind
of like parties
i think those are great i love the fact
that our former presidents
throw parties and rallies that's great
you know what else would be some cool
parties
since we're on the subject of partying
how about just the facts only cdc party
that would be awesome i would love to
attend that
that'd be easy guest list and uh
how about a no free money is good money
party that'd be phenomenal
we can all get back to work and pull our
own weight and
get back to doing the things that make
this country great again and then again
of course
there's my favorite party the you must
be taller than
five nine to ride this ride party
got felt i know it's you sending these
camera crews around me all the time
i know it's you
five nine that's about right meanwhile
other leaders are doing the same thing
dc mayor bowser was photographed a
masculist at an emergency wedding
reception just after reinstating a mass
mandate for her city
but can you blame her it's very hard to
breathe wearing a mask while doing the
chicken dance
dc is currently averaging one cove at a
death a week
experts say the city has become so
criminally dangerous even kovid doesn't
want to go there
meanwhile who was at lollapalooza the
worst mayor in history
if you ignore bill de blasio it's
chicago's lori lightfoot
despite threatening new lockdowns she's
the mayor who always looks like she just
walked in on a naked jerry nadler
[Laughter]
it's like she just saw something that
she can't ever unsee
but if anybody should be hiding their
face it's her given what she's done to
chicago
but i hope she enjoyed the music if
anything it drowns out the gunfire
but times are different right now we
have health experts sending more mixed
messages than an mri of the president's
brain
and the orders are violated by our
leaders as quickly as they're given
yesterday's censorship becomes
tomorrow's fact which i'm good with
i love seeing hypocrites in action for
what you're truly seeing is a division
between the power and the powerless
as well as a new fake justice
masquerading as action
it used to be that laws were for
everyone didn't matter who you are
not so now we now have laws and
restrictions for the law abiding only
and then no laws at all for those who
don't you could be mandated to do this
and do that but no such efforts are
directed at the shoplifters the looters
the homeless encampments
populating the cities so when there's a
dramatic surge in crime the instinct is
not to go after the criminal but to
create more restrictions
for people who already follow them
imagine a fire alarm
when pulled sends the trucks to places
that aren't on fire
that is the new strategy here it's why
now with kovid the powerful makes
sweeping judgments about americans who
might have good bad or even insane
reasons not to be vaccinated or to wear
a mask
they mock them call them stupid call
them killers but they wouldn't dare
stand in the way of a man walking out of
a walgreens with enough product to keep
jesse waters heir standing on end for
eternity
they wouldn't dare try to get the
transients off the street or the
harassing panhandlers
overwhelming the subways that would take
guts
so instead they call you names then they
throw a party it's the gutfeld golden
rule
one enters politics to become immune to
the laws one creates for others
but i say if obama could party so can we
it's time to be inspired by him
and get back to what americans do best
which is doing whatever the hell you
want
and then later if your cat waking up in
your neighbor's tool shed
we now got more cats than an unmarried
white woman culture writer and novelist
cat rosenfield
he gets his wardrobe from the dumpster
outside a funeral home
fox news radio simi fella
she knows how to light up a room like
when she sets an ex's home on fire
fox news contributor cat tim
and you know he's close when your dishes
start vibrating
my massive sidekick and joseph enough
said on fox nation tyrus
jimmy you appear to be splattered in
covid
it seriously looks like a virus vomited
on you
uh where do you where do you stand on
the i'm going to you first for that
reason
because again you were dressed
atrociously well i was going to say
shame on you and tyrus you're supposed
to be my friends
i look like a couch that should be
covered in plastic yeah
you should have told me this before i
walked out of the florida home wearing
the living room furniture
yes whoever died in that i don't know
what they died from but
embarrassment over 80s exposure yes
so what do you where do you stand on the
of it's
the hypocrisy accusation is so obvious
is there something more to it than that
well i do laugh at the idea that they're
going to have a covid coordinator is
what they're calling it
which is a really fancy way of saying
someone who walks around and tells you
not to put anything on social media
because that's all that means they're
not coordinating like that good point
like that on its face is absurd um you
know to the point of obama throwing the
party though the nice thing is if you do
get sick at the party
and you like your doctor you can keep
your doctor which is good
a throwback yeah there you go old school
but did you notice by the way
that this uh particular house has a
private runway which means on top of all
the other hypocrisy
nobody's flying commercial shindig
nobody's worried about reducing their
carbon footprint
and that's the fraud of the whole thing
it goes past covet when you talk about
muriel bowser in the mask thing that's
obviously absurd
right like when she says we're all in
this together she means uh the cocktail
hour
yeah we're all in this together it takes
forever to get a drink this sucks
yeah yeah yeah but that's like the
reality of who these people are the
reason we don't take any public health
initiative seriously is the people
passing them don't take them seriously
right so how are you supposed to take
any of it seriously you know
to the lorry lightfoot point though i
will say when it comes to la la palooza
uh kova's not in the top 20 things to
catch at la la palooza
can we like cover if they tell you you
caught covert at lollapalooza you're
like oh thank god
you know i before i go to
the the new cat not the old cat but the
new cat i
would say that lollapalooza is that age
group now
those people are in their 50s so the
only disease they're spreading is maybe
uh i don't know
art arthritis a lot of passing
i am the king of arthritis information
welcome to the show thank you okay i
don't have a problem with the party but
doesn't
president obama he has enough love does
he really need to throw a party for
himself
i don't know i think he deserves to be
happy yes you know to have a good time i
feel like you know but i mean haven't we
all learned that at this
point the thing that kind of fascinates
me is that uh
the way that all of this stuff is
getting talked about and even like the
coveted mitigation measures the way that
those are being talked about
it's sort of like people are are feeling
this delusion that we have a lot more
control over our own mortality
uh than we actually do as if like
if you catch this virus and you get sick
um
it's not because the virus did what it's
evolved over the course of millennia to
do it's because you just didn't try hard
enough
right you didn't care enough yeah yeah
no that's a good point it's a good point
that's why like i think these days kat
we can't understand costs and benefits
or the risks of our lives so we need to
stamp out everything
which we know is impossible clearly yeah
it's impossible we're all gonna die
some of us faster than others yes uh i
have my money on you before me
oh you know it could happen um
which is kind of the point and i
completely agree with you i just think
it you know it's
it's really a window into why they have
this attitude these politicians who put
these rules in place i mean like it's
just like the just in front of stay home
it's not stay home
it's just stay home like it's no big
deal because they can just
kind of put these things in place
depending on what works for
their own social schedule it's not that
hard to do
cat it's not that hard we were saying
that on the five while we were still
working
right oh just stay home another day
that's right but i'm doing the show from
home
right i wouldn't dare because i've still
gotten to work this entire time oh just
stay home i think your livelihood your
life no big deal
yeah it's so funny yeah it's a brilliant
point because you know when you talk
about accommodating their social
schedule
muriel bowser put this mandate into
effect for 7 a.m saturday morning after
the wedding
after after the wedding it was done but
i love how they set this up like covet
is arriving by the waze app and it has a
set eta
yeah no no it says i'll be there at 7 00
am saturday morning i just got to get
off of the left here
what do you think tyrus i got kind of
you're the gist from your angry black
blackmail
i mean i'm all for the party i'm excited
i got invited
[Laughter]
but when did i mean every time i get on
my
seven-year-old or my nine-year-olds to
stay in school
i can't do it anymore because they
already figured out they'd be like
dad the politicians argued the same way
we do
tommy's having a party why can't i like
literally that's what we've turned into
that's the news now
guess what the other side did today they
had fun everyone goes
oh yeah you guys had fun three months
ago like that
seriously what we're dealing with now
instead of giving us information about
covid we're getting
barack obama's throwing a party
president trump did a rally
thousands of people showed up they were
excited and happy they did it on purpose
like what are we doing
yeah just tell the news like relax it's
called fill and film content
what he what he's saying is the only
person we should be mad at is fouchy
because he's the worst
and we just agree that's what he said
we just need more adults in the room it
doesn't parties shouldn't matter
rallies shouldn't matter it's a variant
give us the information we'll take it
from there hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it
anywhere else